you know it is the largest largest
school in the world it is online it is
free and it it's expanding we'll talk to
the founder and the winner of a two
million dollar prize from Google okay so
it was two years ago today that Google
announced project ten to the hundredth
the goal was to change the world by
helping people Google got a hundred and
fifty thousand entries and today the
company announced five winners one is
the Khan Academy which is a nonprofit
that lets the world learn for free
through its 1,600 online videos now the
man behind the Khan Academy is Saum
economy joins us now live from Google
headquarters in Mountain View California
happy day for you it is it's pretty
exciting listen so tell us what do you
what do you plan to do with all it with
Google money well as you mentioned Khan
Academy right now it's it's actually
pushing close to 2,000 videos they've
all been produced by me what we're gonna
do two things with the money we're going
to one translate a lot of the content
into some of the world's major languages
Spanish Mandarin Arabic Hindi Portuguese
well I could keep going on and on and
we're going to build out the software
part of what we did I built out the
first version but really what this is
gonna allow us to do is become more than
more than just me we're gonna be able to
hire a team and turn it into an all-out
virtual school yeah sorry yeah that's
what people are wondering that's what I
mean that's the obvious question how do
you do it how do you do school online
and is it actually viable does it work
well you know there's two parts of
school one is the learning part and one
is the credentialing part where we're
tackling the learning part first and I
think it does work I think when people
go to the site bill they'll see that
they're there's a lot of testimonials
from a lot of people who are who are not
just using this as a supplement they're
using this as kind of their their
substitute sometimes for what what maybe
should go on in the classroom so so
there's you know we get we get hundreds
of letters a day from learners all over
the world who
who who used this as their primary way
to learn so listen you were can we say
that you were one of the tech guys right
did you do that before I know that you
worked in money and business I think you
were a hedge fund you worked in hedge
funds right so how did you just how did
you just decide to change and say you
know what I'm gonna deal with education
gonna deal with education and teaching
online well you know there was there was
always a part of me that what they
wanted to do something in education
about five years ago I had a family
member in New Orleans I was in Boston at
the time who who needed help with math
so I started tutoring or remotely and
then I started tutoring her brothers and
it started going really well but it
became hard to schedule time so I said
hey let me let me put the let me do my
lectures on YouTube so that we can we
don't have to schedule our time and
their feedback immediately was that he
liked me better on YouTube than in
person they got the thing they got the
pause and repeat and I guess there
wasn't the stress of a live interaction
with their cousin and I also made it
free for anybody else and I started
getting letters from random people all
over the world saying that these videos
allowed them to pass algebra or these
videos are the reason why they didn't
drop out of school or why they're able
to go back to college and I just got
excited about it I was doing it
part-time it really is a hobby while as
you mentioned working at a hedge fund
and then the site kept growing until
last year where it got too exciting for
me to be able to focus on my head job
slide so I quit and and I lived off the
savings for a little bit we got a few
donations earlier this year that allowed
me to take a small salary but this this
Google award really allows us to take it
to the next level and turn into a real
free virtual school was your reaction
when you got the Google award I'm sure
you were static because this I mean this
really helps things help smooth move
things along
oh yeah it's super exciting I mean you
know obviously the money is huge we'll
be able to build out a team we'll be
able to internationalize the content so
that more than just English speakers you
know we can start you know addressing
the other five billion people on the
world and I think probably the biggest
thing is that it's it's you know the
Google people are pretty serious
thinkers and they wouldn't be throwing
or occurring around two million dollars
for just any effort so I think this is a
pretty strong validation for what I want
to ask you this you know the movie
Waiting for Superman opens today and
it's about education and everyone is
trying to figure out how do we fix the
American educational system
have any advice from what you are doing
that we can you know learn from for our
schools the brick-and-mortar schools
yeah you know I think people have been
talking about technology being a major
factor for a while now I think the
problem is is that all the attempts so
far using technology have been kind of
to mold the technology to the
traditional academic model what we're
trying to do is really just rethink how
you can learn now using technology and
maybe we should mold the traditional
academic model too to how we can use
technology but I could go on and on and
about that but I think you're gonna see
some major changes in the next five to
ten years Salman Khan from the Khan
Academy congratulations and we'll be
looking to see what you are doing with
that money and and how it helps your
effort there thanks again okay thank you